i
hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en español colombia se
encuentra a las puertas de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
que tendrán lugar el próximo 19 de junio
luego de que en la primera vuelta el
candidato de izquierda gustavo petro
llevará más del 40 por ciento de los
votos seguidos por rodolfo hernández del
movimiento de liga de gobernantes
anticorrupción que no obtuvo una cifra
un poco superior al 28 por ciento de los
sufragios nos acompaña en esta
oportunidad marc el encaste sión fórmula
vicepresidencial de rodolfo hernández
ella es licenciada en biología y química
también ingeniera industrial y tiene
maestría en administración y gestión de
empresas marel en castillo muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en la
entrevista de france 24 en español bueno
el posicionamiento de hernández y
también es suyo por supuesto ha ido
creciendo muchísimo lo que fue el último
tramo de la campaña verdad para muchos
de hecho el resultado fue una gran
sorpresa que atribuye ese desempeño de
la primera vuelta
bueno te hago muchas cosas
la primera como tú dices en la primera
vuelta muchos nos decían porque a mí me
lo decían en diferentes escenarios
ustedes van a ser un buen tercero y las
encuestas siempre nos tuvieron como
terceros que al final estuvimos subiendo
poco a poco pero se dio un cambio
asia en la recta final y ya pusimos a
las elecciones y los resultados pues nos
tienen hoy aquí con aproximadamente 6
millones de votos que para nosotros esto
es
y demostrar el cambio real que quiere el
país es la transformación cuando tú me
preguntas qué pasó a una campaña
totalmente diferente porque nuestra
campaña
la experiencia totalmente las campañas
tradicionales yo desde mi lenguaje yo la
llamo una campaña disruptiva hemos
trabajado es con el pueblo a través de
los medios digitales de las redes
sociales llevando el mensaje y bajo un
trabajo muy cercano en la región a
sistemas las comunicaciones y los medios
y las redes que mostraban la región y lo
que hemos trabajado con la gente con
nuestro voluntario lo dentista se maneja
con trabajo de emoción y este trabajo
emoción está fundamentado en esta
transformación real que quieren los
colombianos eso es lo que nos tiene hoy
aquí en la segunda vuelta representamos
la diferencia no somos más ni de un lado
ni otro ni el partido ni de colores sino
que le damos una opción diferente a los
colombianos para bien hablaba usted de
la campaña de las estrategias verdad y
usted es una de las cabezas detrás de
esa estrategia digital es de hernández
especialmente en redes sociales como por
ejemplo 'tik tok' atribuye sus
resultados al menos en parte no a este
trabajo en las redes
y no solamente de las redes sino también
en el trabajo en la región y yo tengo la
oportunidad de recorrer el país estar en
diferentes regiones del ingeniero
fernández también pero las redes
en la red en este momento si son
significan esa esa diferencia que hemos
marcado ingeniero fernández tenemos en
campaña un grupo de jóvenes experto en
redes en comunicaciones en llevar el
mensaje y bueno hoy toda esta
transformación digital todo lo que
embargo a los medios digitales y las
redes nos permite llevar el mensaje de
una manera más rápida de una manera
sencilla y llegar a más personas
sobra decir porque en colombia y región
en donde no hay conectividad y pues
donde no hay conectividad hemos
utilizado los medios la radio pero
también nosotros hemos hecho la visita
no tenemos más indagado un grupo que es
el grupo de los apóstoles hemos
denominado y ese grupo de los apóstoles
tienen tienen se les ha asignado cada
uno sola en el país de aquí donde el
ingeniero rodolfo hernández en un billón
no puede estar tenemos los apóstoles que
van llevando nuestra propuesta de
gobierno en las diferentes regiones
acompañada de lo que tú mismo
manifiestas que son las redes
marina en la campaña ha estado bastante
tensionada especialmente en este último
tramo verdad de hecho rodolfo hernández
anunció que suspendería sus apariciones
públicas por amenazas contra su vida que
nos puede decir al respecto que se sabe
de las amenazas y cuál es la situación
de seguridad de hernández
y lastimosamente en esta contienda
el edificio donde se hacen amenazas a la
vida del ingeniero les toca tomar
decisiones hoy nos acompañan pues toda
la fuerza pública del ministerio de
interior
ha reforzado todo nuestro esquema de
seguridad el ingeniero rodolfo hernández
tenía varias visitas teníamos planeada
visita diferentes regiones en colombia
pero por su seguridad escribimos que
esas visitas pues no se realizan para
atender todo a través de los medios
digitales de las redes
de la conectividad por videoconferencia
le está atendiendo y se desplazará
solamente a las regiones donde sean
necesarios tenemos que esta semana
tenemos unos compromisos en facultades
que estaban dándose el cumplimiento pero
ahora lo más importante es velar con la
seguridad y por la vida del ingeniero
rodolfo fernández que tenemos todo el
respaldo de la institucionalidad en
colonias es muy lastimoso este hecho
porque no nos permite hacer un ejercicio
de campaña cerca de la gente
compartiendo con ellos que la gente
quiere verlos quiere que el ingeniero
esté en las regiones quiere tener esa
cercanía y así y así ha sido toda
nuestra campaña hemos estado en región
del ingeniero ha estrechado la mano de
los colombianos ha compartido con ellos
y era nuestra propuesta para trabajar
esta semana espero pues lastimosamente
hay que velar por la seguridad del y
hablemos ahora de otra polémica en la
que se ha visto envuelto hernández a
partir de varios dichos suyos no como ha
sentido cómo se ha sentido usted cuando
escuchó comentarios al menos
desafortunados no pues de alguna manera
respecto de las mujeres por parte de
rodolfo hernández como que la gente por
ejemplo no le gusta que esté en el
gobierno que son vistas como invasivas
que mejor apoyen desde la casa entre
otros comentarios que muchos consideran
misóginos que siente usted cuando
escucha esto ha hablado con hernández al
respecto
no ves que es de los contextos son todos
vídeos sacados del contexto se han
editado se han sacado del contexto real
claro que hemos conversado con el
ingeniero rodolfo hernández
y me manifestaba en diferentes
escenarios es con evidencias con ellos
fuera de contexto y se igual los
diferentes medios pero si no le avisaron
uno muy interesante donde el ingeniero
rodolfo hernández
manifiesta que es a él le gusta trabajar
con mujeres porque somos muy
trabajadoras como muy organizada
manejamos muy bien la financiación with
latina alta somos muy concluido horas
entonces ese signo lo viralizado pero a
la muestra
y con hechos y evidencias su fórmula
vicepresidencial es una mujer a la cual
él respeta mucho me trata con mucho
respeto trabajamos como tuiteros
trabajamos muy bien pero además
activamos a quien maneja nuestra campaña
tiene la gerente de campaña la dirigente
de campaña es la esposa del ingeniero de
fernández la doctora socorro que ha
hecho un trabajo ejemplar
coherente con nuestra propuesta tiene
gastos excesivos con eficiencia hemos
invertido en lo que se requiere en la
primera campaña le ahorramos al país
aproximadamente
23 mil millones de pesos y ellas en la
que evidencia la campaña pero ella
también en la que lleva las finanzas de
su empresa familiar y el protagonismo
que tiene la mamá del ingeniero
fernández en su vida como en las respeta
como es la sigue además con evidencias y
ellos en la gestión que él hizo en la
alcaldía de bucaramanga
aproximadamente el 70 por ciento
del equipo que lo acompañó bien y en
nuestro programa de gobierno la
propuesta es muy clara el 60 por ciento
t la del ejecutivo que nos acompaña será
muy bien
con hechos y evidencia dice se acabe
contexto pero no en lo que esté en esos
vídeos sino los derechos y las
evidencias que demuestran tener línea
que el ingeniero rodolfo hernández
trabaja en la mano de la nube y aquí
está marilyn castilla bueno pero más
allá de los contextos cuando habla de la
mujer como administradora o
particularmente organizada que maneja la
finanza no crees que quizás de cierta
forma está reforzando algún tipo de
estereotipo cultural sobre lo femenino
no no no
a base a eso es el respaldo a la gestión
la mujer como participe nosotras hoy de
las tomas de decisiones y lo estoy
haciendo en este momento con la
oportunidad que nos da el país de tomar
decisiones en lo político en lo social
en lo económico y tenemos esa
posibilidad y lo hacemos en los
diferentes roles que asumimos como el
que estoy asumiendo hoy como la fórmula
vicepresidencial del ingeniero hernández
bueno y que lo he hecho en el transcurso
de mi vida profesional con 32 años que
es servir a la educación en roles
académicos administrativos en la mayor y
mayor tiempo como directivo donde se
hace el reconocimiento y no solamente mi
labor sino hay muchas mujeres en
colombia que hoy cumplimos este rol y
hoy tenemos la oportunidad de ser parte
de esta toma de decisiones
ahora las dos mujeres que aspiran a la
vicepresidenta son ambas afro
colombianas porque francia márquez va
con gustavo petro ambas atravesadas por
supuestos por historias y experiencias
muy diferentes para algunos analistas su
perfil es quizás por samán o alguna
manera menos combativo que el de francia
y esto la acercaría más a sectores de
tinte más conservadores así que las
acerca de que la diferencia
no mira eso la pregunta de diferentes
escenarios y realmente tal vez estaba
preocupada y no he tenido el espacio a
sentar a hacer esas comparaciones de que
me acerca o que me aleje pero si quieres
ver el castillo para el castillo como tú
lo dices hoy apro descendiente soy de la
zona pacífica soy una mujer criada en
una familia de nuestro medio donde le
enseñaron que lo que hay que hacer en la
vida para salir adelante es estudiar no
mencionabas al inicio hice primero mi
licenciatura en biología química me
vinculé a la ausencia por muchos años
estuve en el aula de clase sellando
química física biología matemáticas
después el estudio hacer otra carrera
estudia la ingeniería industrial y bueno
empiezo a hacer un cambio en mi vida y
hace 22 años llegó a la educación
superior la educación superior llegó a
desempeñar cargos en la dirección
académica administrativa
como decana como vicerrectora pero toda
esa ruta de formación para mí siempre es
complementar seguir formándome desde
amigos
administración posteriormente mi
doctorado y eso me ha permitido pues
estar en una de las universidades más
grandes de colombia en mi minuto ser su
vicerrectora general académica por la
rectora de mi punto virtualidad
instancia la directora de iniciativas
estratégicas y liderar proyectos de
crecimiento al interior de la
institución entonces daniel en castillo
a través del estudio del legado que me
me dieron mis padres pues a tener unas
oportunidades de trabajar en educación y
al servicio de la educación y desde ese
rol de desempeño entonces como te digo
no no soy partidaria de esas
comparaciones creo que cada persona
bajo su estilo bajo las oportunidades
bajo el contexto que le ha tocado que ha
desarrollado y poco a poco pues va
alcanzando unos puntos unos puntos de
equilibrio para desempeñar actividades
que se le encomienda en este caso la que
hoy tengo a mi cargo es debe ser la
cantidad de la fórmula presidencial del
ingeniero rodolfo hernández por mis
competencias por mi experiencia por mi
recorrido a caer mal en castillo
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 en español a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a que sigan informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y
también por supuesto entradas 24 punto
com sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]